seit dem tod von george wright am 25
was ist seitdem in den usa passiert was
hat sich vor allem verändert ja wirklich
der tod von george wright hat hier einen
umbruch fast ausgelöst man hat hier
dinge gesehen die man eigentlich für
undenkbar gehalten hat in amerika
wirklich epochale ereignisse wie viele
bereits schreiben eine echte zäsur für
das land die afro amerikaner haben nach
diesem grauenhaften video gesagt es
reicht wir haben genug es kann so nicht
mehr weitergehen das hatte diese fälle
immer wieder gegeben
in den letzten jahren und menschen haben
protestiert es ging durch die medien
nach ein paar tagen war alles wieder
ruhig und die unterdrückung der
amerikaner ist weitergegangen
und natürlich auch die über harte
haltung vieler police departments in den
usa die hochgerüstet wurden teilweise
sogar mit waffen die aus der us armee
ausgemustert werden die dann in die
polizei die stände übergingen all das
hat zu einer wut zu einem frust geführt
bei der amerikanischen bevölkerung auch
anderen minderheiten in den usa und der
tod von george floyd hat hier wirklich
was bull verfasst zunächst zur explosion
gebracht das hat man gesehen bei diesen
teilweise gewalttätigen unruhen dann
allerdings eine massenbewegung die hier
entstanden ist mit friedfertigen
demonstrationen die zahlreiche us
metropolen praktisch lahmgelegt haben
allerdings alles mit friedfertigen
methoden und jetzt natürlich dieser tag
der trauer der eingehen wird in die
annalen americas und auch hier wird
natürlich hingewiesen welche bedeutung
dieser tod hat von george freude und das
ist hier einfach so nicht mehr
weitergehen kann dieses land hat
sehnsucht nach sozialer veränderung nach
einer integration der besonders der
afroamerikaner einer einer reformen
wo sich diese bevölkerungsgruppe nicht
mehr unter druck drückt viel wenn man
hier redet mit afro amerikanern gibt es
immer ein leitmotiv dass sie eben angst
haben dass sie ständig aufgehalten
werden dass sie ständig verfolgt werden
dass sie ständig verdächtigt werden
und das alles ist bei diesem in diesem
letzten zwei wochen praktisch zur
explosion gekommen hier in amerika wir
sehen gerade die livebilder aus der
kirche ist es gerade ein kunstwerk auch
entstanden in der kirche dort
und dass seine private
trauerveranstaltung familie freunde
angehörige von george floyd wie viele
menschen sind ungefähr gekommen sowohl
in die kirche als auch drum rum sind
viele menschen trotzdem da um ihre
anteilnahme zu zeigen die solidarität du
hast es auch schon gesagt auf der ganzen
welt ist groß wie es jetzt gerade die
situation in houston vor ort diese
memorial feier wurde so organisiert dass
es eine mehr oder weniger eine private
feier ist für eben familienmitglieder
und andere geladene gäste 500 personen
sind in der kirche mehr wurden nicht
zugelassen das fassungsvermögen wurde
erreicht natürlich privat ist ein
falsches wort eigentlich weil es wird
natürlich in alle welt übertragen aber
der abschied für die öffentlichkeit für
jedermann hat am vortag stattgefunden am
montag da haben tausende abschied
genommen am tag an diesem goldenen sarg
von trott der offen aufgebaut wurde der
hier ganz still lag in diesen goldenen
sagen wirklich berührender moment ein
bewegender moment wo viele menschen fast
in tränen ausgebrochen sind und
praktisch überwältigt wurden von ihren
emotionen heute allerdings die
offizielle trauerfeier neben mit vielen
star rednern wie elle schafften und
anderen politikern und außerhalb war
sind einige schaulustige gekommen
allerdings ist das areal für die breite
bevölkerung eigentlich abgeriegelt
worden es gibt ja sehr viel
sicherheitsbarrieren zugelassen
draußen vor der vor dieser kirche sind
eigentlich nur journalisten die
weltpresse allerdings dann wenn es
weitergeht zum begräbnis zur echten
bestattung auf einem friedhof in einem
satz von houston
dort wird doch erwartet dass wieder
viele tausend schaulustige die straße
säumen könnten und einfach toll freut
die letzte ehre erweisen wollen